baby what if you instead of having
decoration in your house about your old
trips
i want to see things that remind me of
my country
not your
stupid ex-wife
stupid
you have a problem
i don't think you need to say she's
stupid but oh she's intelligent you're
wonderful perfect ex-wife
no i just don't think you should say
stupid she's just my ex-wife and that's
that
she's stupid to me
i i hate that you know has a pass
he has been married before with a
brazilian girl
and i saw some video chat his house
screams hair every corner
[Music]
but
if we're gonna have my future together
and you're expecting me to move to the
united states i don't wanna live in a
house that someone else decorated
so pick up a magnet and i want to see
when you replace it with the other
panama yes i'm trying to see which one i
like one that says panama big letters
this one here
oh this is phenomenal
got like the beach and peanuts oh yes
let's take it baby come
over the last nine months with jasmine
one thing i've learned to do is not talk
about my axes
okay baby thirteen dollars both 13. okay
because there's been a couple of times
where
she got so upset
that she wouldn't talk to me until the
next day
we are gonna forget about the ghosts
from the past they are dead
okay
oh baby
but there's things jasmine doesn't know
about my exes
and knowing what i know about jasmine's
jealousy
i worry about what she would do if she
ever found out that i was still
friends with one of my exes
[Music]
you